Paul and I have a little history
together and I should be upfront about
that right now
no I see the other way really not whoa
worthy there's a gym here I hope so for
me it was I'm not married anymore so I
can say that look at the corner you're I
know okay yeah well let's explain what
we're talking about there's a gym here
at Warner Brothers and I don't just get
this body you got to work for it any
works hard and so I used to go to the
gym and I remember the first time I went
and out of the corner of my eye I saw
you corner my eyes I was like this and
you were doing Tae Bo kicking and all
that and I'd be in the corner doing two
three pound weights and staring at you
through like I'd always stand behind a
plant so I could peer at you this looks
bad what I'm doing I look uh you know I
apologize for that but what was weird
too is there's no plants in that gym he
would bring a flat platinum yeah I
called it my Paula Patton plant and I
set it down and stare at you like a
creep
you